ragazzi io non ho veramente parola cioè
non sono anche come iniziarlo questo
video premetto che sabato sera ed ero
fuori era uscito perché il sabato sera
in genere esco perché se non sto a
montare i video tutto il giorno però
sono rientrati in casa perché è successa
una roba c'è indecente c'è veramente
successo norma indecente
non so se avete visto il video di
stamattina vabbè facevo la reaction ad
una ragazza dove lei spiega un po le
usanze italiane c'è io non
da quando ho fatto quel video li un
sacco di gente è andata sotto il video
di questa ragazza ad insultarla
c'è una minchia mariga ma ce la fate
porca [ __ ] ve lo giuro mi sono ma
neanche incazzato sono amareggiato sono
deluso una cosa che non ha senso ma
perché perché dovreste andare sul video
di una ragazza insultarla dio poi che ho
fatto un video anche la settimana scorsa
dove vi ho spiegato che non ho mai
ascoltato insulti perché per me le
persone che non conosco che mi insultano
non esistono cioè non vale un cazzo un
insulto di una persona che non mi
conosce
cioè mi dice che sei un [ __ ] che
cazzo è non lo conosco neanche
figurazioni offendono ma che ma poi
muori domani ai tempi quando quando la
gente insultava a caso sul web
io non me la prendevo anzi tutti
dicevano fare fa vj non riascoltare a me
non mi fregava niente niente per me di
insulti non esistevano mi accorgo che un
mio video ha generato odio nei confronti
di una persona un mio video
cioè io comunque il video ho fatto
dell'ironia ma ma ma poi mano nella mano
lemme anche ironia perché non c'è niente
neanche così di ironico in quel video
cioè tutto non c'è niente di negativo
nel video che ho fatto stamattina ma
niente lentini negativo perché cazzo
siete andati insultare una ragazza sotto
il suo fido madonna quanto mi fa
imbestialire sta roba
cioè non ha senso perché io che sono la
persona che rispetta il prossimo il più
possibile non mondo merda neanche a kimi
sparava merda una volta perché cioè io
alla fine non voglio ma il male non lo
voglia nessuno non lo voglio neanche al
mio peggior nemico non mi interessa io
non provo odio nei confronti delle
persone perché chi mi segue e deve farlo
perché perché le persone che mi seguono
portare odiano il video nell'altra
personali non lo capisco c'è questa
povera ragazza si è trovata sotto il suo
video sotto il suo profilo degli insomma
degli insulti ma di una cattiveria
incredibile ma perché sono tornato a
casa perché non potevo stare fuori a
guarda perché poi comunque col telefono
guardato guardavo i commenti le joma ma
è normale sta roba
ora io
mi sono scusato con la ragan che se non
ho fatto niente di male comunque mi sono
scusato a nome di chi è andato insultare
la perché comunque erano dei miei
iscritti che sono andati ad insultare
questa ragazza ho scritto questa ragazza
ci siamo già sentiti e le ho chiesto
scusa perchè non non aveva veramente
senso che delle persone andassero ad
insultarla ho fatto un post su instagram
dove ho detto ragazzi andate a farle
vedere che l'italia non è tutta così non
siamo tutti gli stronzi di merda
ma c'è anche gente che porta amore non
porta solo odio ad altre persone infatti
in molti sono andati sotto i suoi
commenti a scrivere cose molto positiva
adesso la situazione si è stabilizzata
del tutto normale adesso la ragazza ha
appreso un botto di follower fin dalla
fine da tutto questo è uscita in super
positivo ha preso un botto di views il
suo video né uscita supervincitrice ma
se lo merita perché sorride ora era un
video bellissima con video super
divertente originale tra l'altro c'è io
ho ironizzato su 23 robe ma più che
quello era un video stupendo ma poi l'ho
anche scritto nella descrizione ma mi
chiama leggete le descrizioni porca
vacca ma anche senza la descrizione si
capiva benissimo che era un video
ironico ma un video reaction video
reaction come to me tanti altri ma hanno
fatto un miliardo mai era successo a
questa roba mai dei miei scritti sono
andati sotto ad un altro video a spalare
merda su una persona non deve non deve
ricapitare mai più rari ha mai più ma
proprio mai mai mai mai nella vita deve
succedere una roba del genere io come
canale su youtube
non porto odio non lo porterò mai non mi
interessa se porto odio lo porto sui
videogiochi brutti che faccio non su
altre persone io sul mio canale non
parlo di altre persone non ho neanche
bisogno
quindi in sintesi io chiedo scusa a
questa ragazza da parte mia per tutti i
miei iscritti perché ovviamente non è
che posso andare tutti a chiedere scusa
scusa io personalmente non avevo alcuna
intenzione negativa ma neanche mezza e
neanche chi mi segue credo abbia
intenzione negative ora sempre nel video
che ho fatto l'altra volta in cui vi
parlavo del fatto che ci sono tanti fan
che o che sono adulti e tanti fan che
sono bambini
siccome c'è questo divario incredibile
molti dei miei video vengono capiti in
un certo modo dalle persone più grandi e
capiti di meno la le persone più piccole
ad esempio se io faccio dell'ironia
magari dei ragazzini non lo capiscono e
vanno ad insultare a manetta una persona
senza neanche aver capito il perché lo
fanno
perché da bambini è una cosa stupida e
quindi lo fanno un po come lieta siete
perché sono bambini perché non capiscono
che l'insulto non serva un cazzo mi
insultano inutile tu sei soltanto una
persona quella persona non si pagherà
mai perché tu non sei nessuno quindi non
l'insulto non esiste cioè il cyber
bullismo è la cosa più inutile del mondo
cioè non vali niente un vissuto sul web
ma neanche nella realtà secondo me dalle
persone che che non che non stimi che
non conosci se una persona ti insulta
come persona non esiste ma a prescindere
non vale niente
l'insulto di una persona che non conosci
ma a parte quello essendo molti fan miei
ragazzini in molti non capiscono e
quindi da adesso in avanti o vi prego di
leggere tutte le descrizioni dei miei
video semmai ci dovessero essere semmai
dovessero essere presenti altre persone
nei miei video
nessuna deve essere minimamente sfiorata
nessuno deve portare negatività ad
un'altra persona in alcun modo non
esiste non è questo lo spirito del mio
canale non è per questo che faccio video
e non fa parte né anche della mia
persona a parlare negativamente le
persone per me è una cosa che non esiste
dopo non esiste ha quindi ragazze per
chi ha fatto questa cosa che sta
seguendo questo video chiedete scusa
immediatamente chiedete scusa se avete
fatto qualcosa di negativo siete scritto
ma non a lei e magari anche in passato
ad altre persone
mai più una roba del genere ma io sono
tornato a casa sono ero amareggiato
adesso un po mi sono ripreso perché
invece da quando ho spiegato la
situazione su instagram molti stanno
condividendo messaggi positivi nei
confronti della ragazza su tutti i suoi
profili quindi la situazione si è
stabilizzata io faccio questo video
semplicemente per evitare che tutto
questo possa ri succedere in futuro
perché non ha veramente senso però che
questo video sia stato utile in qualche
modo spero che non ricapiti mai una roba
del genere e dimostriamo almeno una
volta per cortesia che l'italia non è un
paese che arriva sempre ultimo nelle
cose siamo anche un paese che sa portare
bontà non solo negatività in giro quindi
fate vedere che l'italia è un paese che
ha valori ha qualcosa da poter dare agli
altri non solo negatività
vi prego dai ragazzi